congressman jim jordan from ohio the
cleveland indians becoming the cleveland
guardians today ben shapiro
tweeting out next on the chopping block
atlanta braves kansas city chiefs golden
state warriors chicago blackhawks back
with the panel
trey thoughts i
don't care i pull for the other ohio
baseball team and we have
our problems i do think it's ironic that
cleveland calls their team the guardians
given their crime rate
but then again los angeles calls their
team the angels and that's pretty ironic
too
then
the irony of the term woke is that is
designed to keep people asleep
asleep to the realities of the problems
that happen within these leagues
within these teams it's as performative
as anything else when you have these
types of name changes
it's all about looking in the other
direction and it's as silly
as jeff bezos thanking all those amazon
employees for
peeing in bottles so that he could play
space cowboy for a few minutes
harold there's a lot there
uh look i think political correctness
has gotten way out of hand
but i do think there's certain
historical sensitivities that that
should not be used to demean
people or demean parts of our history
and these are simple things that we can
change no one in cleveland is not going
to root any harder for
their team against the reds nor the reds
are going to rule any harder or less
because they're called the guardians
yeah so the washington change in their
washington redskins and others changing
names i grew up with the redskins now
they're the football team so it's
something i can live with it won't
change the way i think about the teams
i'd just like a name for washington
eventually all right here's uh president
biden on inflation from the cnn
town hall prices are up now
and they're up in for example you're in
a position where
you're trying to build a house try to
find two by fours and lumber
well guess what people stop working
cutting lumber
they stopped doing it because they their
their unemployment was
so down now all of a sudden there's this
need because people are coming back and
guess what
instead of paying 10 cents you're paying
20. i mean you understand what i'm
saying
it relates to what in fact is now
needed because we're growing trey kind
of got himself in a verbal
cul-de-sac there he almost said because
they were getting unemployment checks i
think
he was getting down that road
yeah when he said you understand what
i'm saying actually i have no idea
what he was saying i it sounded to me
that
prices are going up because uh we are
paying people to stay
home which is also his fault you got
high crime high inflation
and a poorest border that's a recipe to
be a one-term president
ben we have a president who has
definitely embraced that michael scott
quote about
starting a sentence without knowing
where he's going to end up at the end
and i will just say that yes that's
exactly i think brett
where he was going with that sentence
before he realized uh
what would result from that you can't
though i think blame this on any
on anything else other than the white
house actual policy all right
lightning winners and losers harold
first you winner than loser
my winner is adam silver my honorable
mentions roger goodell they
adam silver got us through two seasons
we've got a new champion uh
milwaukee my pal mark lazary and giannis
congratulate you guys congratulations
roger goodell's figured out also
how to get more players vaccinated and
my loser again people who don't realize
that china and russia wins
when we don't get vaccinated we can't
open our schools we can't get this
economy going like we want
let's all get vaccinated trey winner and
loser
kevin mccarthy because he doesn't have
to participate or be interviewed loser
the d.c
media because they can never find fault
with nancy pelosi no matter how many
mistakes she makes
ben wrap us up winner and loser winner
winner university of texas university of
oklahoma if this
merger goes through with the sec loser
everybody else left in the dead big 12
sad thing to see go there we go bring us
home
all right panel thanks make it a great
weekend